october is breast cancer awareness month
and in honor of this very important
month we're catching up with an
inspirational breast cancer survivor who
is very near and dear to us we met
cheryl kolberg last season when she was
planning something special for her 50th
birthday to support finding a cure
here's an update on what she's been up
to since and what she's planning for
breast cancer awareness month this year
this woman is truly one of my heroes
she's just incredible please take a look
hey drew it's sheryl kohlberg thanks for
having me back this year i just wanted
to give you an update in
2018 i was diagnosed with breast cancer
i was in treatment for 15 months it was
very difficult but i made it through and
i've been cancer-free for almost two
years now for me running has always been
a part of my life and now that i'm
cancer-free the journey back to health
one of the things that was really
important for me was to get back into
running again
so last year it was my 50th birthday i
wanted to do something very special to
celebrate i
met people from all 50 states and ran
virtually with someone from each state
every day for 50 days over zoo i've met
so many amazing people through this
process some women who
literally have told me that because they
saw me on the show
they went and got their mammogram and
they found out they had breast cancer
they got it detected early enough and
they're fine thanks to wonderful
supporters like you drew and
bank of america i was able to raise more
than a hundred thousand dollars
for susan g komen to hopefully put a
cure to breast cancer
this year i'm doing something different
i'm running a 5k every day in october
and i'm encouraging people to join me
where they are they can run bike swim
and
take a photo of what you're doing post
it to your social media and mention at
55o for the cure i want to give hope to
women who are currently
in treatment and let them know that
someday soon they'll be in my shoes out
running again or doing whatever they
love to do i encourage everyone to get
involved and raising awareness for
breast cancer
together one mile at a time
we are so inspired by you cheryl and we
are rooting for you always don't forget
to get your mammograms and visit the 50
forthcured.org to join cheryl or to
learn more
[Music]